well this is a huge blow to the
Republican Party guys a huge blow
Hillary Clinton has announced that she
is not running for president in 2020
absolute tragedy
oh I'm thinking of starting a petition
to urge her to get into the race maybe a
GoFundMe or something like that
we need her in the race there's there's
still time but we need her to jump in it
would be hugely unfortunate if she
doesn't run for president on a better
note though a group of environmental
activists are staging what they call a
birth strike they've they taken a pledge
to refrain from having kids until
climate change stops not gonna have any
kids until there's no more until the
climate stops changing until it's a
steady you know 70 degrees and sunny
everywhere on the planet forever they're
not gonna have any kids blithe pepino is
one of the one of the invite just sounds
like the name of an environmental
activists who would do something like
this doesn't it for some reason blithe
pepino says that she told a BBC News she
says the natural world is collapsing
around us and that's actually happening
right now and so I'm so disappointed by
the response by our authorities to this
crisis and so freaked out by it
everything I've read that I've basically
last year I came to the decision that I
couldn't bring a child into that now I
want to say that I am fully in favor of
their plan in favor of it for them for
them that is not for me or for you know
rational people but for them I'm fully
in favor of it although it does make me
suspicious that they're talking about a
birth strike and not necessarily a
conception strike so as long as this is
we're not going to have kids because
we're not going to conceive them then I
think for them that's a great idea if
it's we're not going to have kids
because we're gonna kill them in the
womb then I think that it's of course
horrible but you know this is this is
precisely my problem with climate
alarmists
usually is that they don't have the
follow-through now these this collection
of
people they have some follow-through
they're gonna make some actual changes
yeah it's kind of nutty but they are
going to make some changes to their life
and and and they're gonna follow through
on that but usually I find that climate
alarmists especially the prominent
famous ones don't have any kind of
follow through at all they make these
dramatic declarations about about the
end of the world but then they provide
very little evidence through their
actions that they actually believe
anything that they're saying so Exhibit
A would be AOC Alexandria okay CEO
Cortes according to the New York Post is
leaving an enormous Lea large carbon
footprint herself even as she warns that
the world is coming to an end
because of our collective carbon
footprint so reading a little bit from
the Post report it says since declaring
her candidacy in May 2017 Ocasio Cortes
is campaign heavily relied on those
combustion engine cars even though a
subway station was just 138 feet from
her campaign office she listed 1049
transactions for uber lyft Juneau and
other car services federal filings show
this is this is I mean think of how much
she's contributed to the end of the
world by with those 1049 transact think
about how many polar bears
this woman has drowned
by by these these uber rides I mean
justjust think about they think of all
the all the Penguins that are that are
drowning as well the campaign had 505
Luber expenses alone in all o kzo
Cortez's kzo cortez spent twenty nine
thousand three hundred sixty-five
dollars and seventy cents on those
emissions spewing vehicles along with
cars and van rentals even though her
Queens headquarter was a one minute walk
to the seven train the campaign shelled
out only eight thousand three hundred
thirty-five dollars and forty one cents
on fifty two metro card transactions the
article goes on her campaign embraced
the friendly skies logging 60
six airline transactions costing over
$25,000 during the campaign season I
mean just one of those trips on an
airplane probably murdered 47 polar
bears just one of them now you multiply
that by 60 she just wiped out probably
half of the polar bear population the
Democratic firebrand or her staff took
Amtrak far less only 18 times most of
the flights came after her primary win
it talks about more you know times what
she was taking SUVs and so on and then
it does get a little bit it gets a
little you know a little too strict I
think later on the article says in a
February 24 24th Instagram video filmed
in her kitchen occasional Cortes railed
against plastic grocery bags then
appeared to toss two of the sacks which
can be recycled into the trash it drives
me crazy she said of plastic bags I wish
they didn't exist in the video Kaiser
Cortez peeled a sweet potato while
calling for a universal sense of urgency
to save the earth but she discarded the
vegetable scraps into the same
receptacle that she just used for the
plastic bags rather than setting the
food waste aside for the compost you
know that but well I know that's that's
a legitimate criticism too because look
if you if you think the world is coming
to an end because of this stuff wouldn't
you be making dramatic changes in your
own life now AOC has dismissed these
criticisms she's tried to make a joke
out of them but there is something
really important here and it's important
because it's part of a larger pattern
and that larger pattern is big-name
climate activists that appear to show no
personal urgency about the issue
themselves climate warriors who by their
own actions do not seem to mean what
they say and this I think is relevant
and and and and important to notice and
discuss
it would be one thing if all of these
planeteers Cortez and gore and all the
rest of them were out in the woods doing
this we don't have to die
there are some people here who do care
so I want you to know that trees really
care I think we are deeply hurting in
America I think we are deeply craving
answers I think that we've lost our
identity as we have evolved into
technology and into industrialized
society bring me to this Cathedral bring
me to those guys bring me to this rock
that has the most incredible life that
makes me feel alive I've looked at clear
cuts and burnt forests and I felt
outraged but I didn't scream and I
didn't cry and I need you
okay see now those people mean it that's
and that's what I expect to see
Alexandra okay so crisis two Cortez
doing and if she was out there doing
that I would say look she
I think she's mentally unstable but she
means what she says at least and I can
respect that but most environmental
activists aren't doing that and I find
that suspicious so here's what it comes
down to if you're an environmental
activist you tell us that we could be
looking at an extinction level event in
just a generation or two our planet is
going to turn into Venus sooner rather
than later right that's what you say
if we don't drastically change the way
that we live
major cities are going to be lost in the
ocean in fact according to Al Gore a few
decades ago or you know a decade and a
half ago New York City was supposed to
already be under the ocean and frankly
maybe it is I haven't been to New York
in a long time as far as I know it's a
water world up there already so that's
what Al Gore said anyway so the world is
already collapsing all around us and
that's what you told us you said that
there's going to be mass starvation
there's going to be you know famine and
all of this stuff even now whenever
there's a hurricane or tornado or a
thunderstorm or even just a snowstorm
you tell us that it's a direct result of
global warming which itself is a direct
result of our modern lifestyle now you
think again I tell you if you're an
environmental activist you think that
when there's a hurricane and people are
dying that that hurricane was caused by
the fact that we drive cars and fly
airplanes never mind the fact that
hurricanes have been happening on the
earth for billions of years but but you
know they were happening long before
humans ever existed but that humans came
into existence and all of a sudden it's
our fault right but that's what you
believe and if you believe that
something that we're doing is causing a
hurricane shouldn't you stop doing that
thing
if there was something that I did that I
really thought might cause a hurricane I
would never do that thing again oh look
I I think it's true that some
environmentalists do make some
sacrifices maybe you do recycle Malik
Cortez doesn't even do that much but
maybe you do maybe you ordered a salad
at Panera Bread for lunch today but for
the most part it seems like you're just
another homo sapien murdering the planet
and cannibalizing the future of our
children but but how could you do that
you think the world is ending for God's
sake what are you doing just sitting
around and living like the rest was
Alexandro kaiser Cortese her excuses was
the excuse that she offered was well I'm
just living in the world you know I'm
I'm in the world too and so I've got to
do what the world is doing well no you
don't you could sacrifice these things
you could say I'm never gonna take an
uber again I'm never gonna get in an
airplane yes it would be a huge
sacrifice it would caught it would make
things more difficult for you
but wouldn't you do that listen if I
actually believed that in the extinction
of all mankind was imminent and that my
lifestyle was directly contributing to
it at a minimum I would never drive a
car again ever at all I would never do
it at a minimum and I would ditch
electricity too I wouldn't eat meat of
any kind I wouldn't buy mass made
consumer products I wouldn't give my
money to companies that that sell items
that were made in factories with big
giant smokestacks because those
smokestacks are literally killing people
according to you and if I believed the
same thing I wouldn't do that how could
I I mean how could I continue on as
normal
what kind of monster would I have to be
basically if I were you I would live
like Mowgli in the jungle I would
befriend a group of wolves and I would
just and I would just live
in the jungle that's that's what I would
do because lives are at stake if I
believed what Alexandria Kaiser Cortez
believed then I would have to come to
the conclusion that it is objectively
immoral to ride in the car because
there'd be there's just no if this is
contributing to the end of the world
within 12 years there is no way to
justify ever doing it ever so look at
the Amish you know the Amish are riding
around in horses and and and they're
living without electricity and they're
not doing that because they think that
the world is going to come to an end
because of climate change but they but
the fact is they are doing it they are
living that way it is possible to live
that way and so if you really believe
this why aren't you living that way it
just doesn't make any sense you can't
tell me that the world is coming to an
end and then go about your day like
nothing is wrong that's a dead giveaway
you see that you don't really believe
what you're saying and then here's the
question if I look around and I notice
that the prominent mouthpieces of this
movement and in fact almost everybody in
the movement doesn't really believe that
the story that they're telling then why
should I believe it now their hypocrisy
doesn't prove that they're wrong so
that's an important point just because
someone's hypocrite doesn't mean that
what they're saying is wrong and in fact
I should also stipulate that just
because someone said something and then
does another thing that doesn't even
necessarily prove that they don't that
they don't believe what they just said
so if somebody says it's wrong to steal
and then they go and they steal that
certainly doesn't prove that stealing
isn't wrong and it also doesn't mean
that they don't believe that stealing is
wrong it could be that they really
believe stealing is wrong and they're
doing what they believe is wrong which
people do all the time right
that's the essence of evil you know
is-is-is uh is doing what you know to be
wrong so that doesn't necessarily prove
anything
but if you look at a particular movement
and you see that almost everybody
involved in the movement and and pretty
much all of the people at the head of
that movement that they all seem to be
demonstrating this hypocrisy then it
starts to make you suspicious and for me
if I've already independently come to
the conclusion that you're wrong about
what you're saying
so I already don't agree with you even
if you lived by what you were saying I
still wouldn't agree but if I have our
if I've come to that conclusion
and then I look and I see that it seems
as though you don't even agree with what
you're saying then what then what are we
even talking about what's the point of
the conversation at that point so I
guess if you're an environmentalist go
and make some drastic changes to the way
that you live which you are morally
obligated
I'm not morally obligated because I
don't believe that if you think that
this is offering in the end of the world
you are morally obligated not me you so
you have to make those changes and if
enough of you do that then maybe the
rest of us will consider possibly taking
you seriously but until then we won't
alright there's an article let's see
here there was an article from the metro
that was making the rounds online
yesterday I want to tell you about it
just because there's there's one point I
want to make let me see if I can pull
this up alright the the headline of the
article is what's it like being Auto
sexual when you're attracted to yourself
it says sexuality is fluid as with lots
of things that can evolve and Boomerang
over time though so often thought about
in binary terms just as with gender
there are many different sexualities
people identify as Auto sexuality is one
such identification that is seldom
talked about it's the idea of being
sexually attracted to yourself and you
can also come
and can also come with being Auto
romantic experiencing the relationship
with yourself as romantic
it could mean being being anyway this
gets a little bit more graphic than I
want to be the point is that there's
this apparently there's this thing
called Auto sexuality where people are
excited by their own reflections and by
themselves and so they fall in love with
themselves there's a woman I think it's
a woman Ghia the towel or vitaliy is
Auto sexual and Auto romantic
okay so Auto sexual an automatic
apparently two different things okay and
she got engaged to marry herself after
proposing to herself in March of 2017
and now here's when when you hear that
description of course the first thing
you think is well that's just narcissism
right that's that's you say you're just
a narcissist you in love with yourself
that's what narcissism is and that's
true right that's that's all that is
it's narcissism so there's nothing new
or innovative going on here but this is
what happens in our culture now right we
take these we take these this just the
latest example we take these age-old
human flaws or sins or perversions or
whatever and we dress them up and we
give them a new name and and and
suddenly it becomes a community it
becomes a movement it becomes a heroic
method of self-expression when really
it's not any of that is it it's it's
something very simple very old very worn
out very small and uninteresting and
degrading but especially with my
generation we think we've we keep
rediscovering all of these flaws and
thinking that we've found something new
and it's some new mode of
self-expression when it really is not at
all and what you find is that really you
can get someone to accept and celebrate
literally any personality trait at all
even really horrible one
like narcissism you can get people to
accept them and celebrate them if you
just give that trait a new kind of
vaguely medical sounding name and then
you put the people with that trait in
contact with each other and so that they
can you know all get together and talk
to each other so for example you could
easily make people proud to be liars if
you just started if you came up with a
new word instead of calling them liers
instead of calling them pathological
liars let's say you called them sicko
phantoms now sicko phantom is just the
word trickster in Latin that's all that
is but instead of calling them
pathological liars let's call them sicko
phantoms and then if you started like an
online forum for all of these people to
get together and commune and tell lies
to each other
the the sicko phantom forum suddenly
although they're all just a bunch of
filthy liars now they become the sicko
phantom community and everything changes
because you got them together with each
other
you gave them a new name and now they're
a community and now they can and now
they can discover that oh you know I
thought there was something wrong with
me because I couldn't stop lying but
then I discovered this community and I
realized that there's nothing wrong with
there's nothing wrong with it because
other people do it and once I discovered
that other people do it too and we could
encourage each other then that means
it's okay not only is it okay but it's
it we should be accepted we are a new
type of person so we see this process
playing out over and over again it's an
interesting cultural phenomenon speaking
before we get to emails
speaking of weird stuff I wanted to
mention this briefly as well according
to the mirror online publication tie and
a nyah nyah
are their names they were a lesbian
couple but then one of them became a man
and now they are husband and wife in a
heterosexual relationship this is
according to an article that also was
going viral online yes
today the actual headline says married
lesbian couple are now husband and wife
after one became a man which of course
that's like saying man and his ham
sandwich are now a football team after
one of them became the 86 Bears in other
words it's nonsense total nonsense it
doesn't mean anything of course the
woman did not become a man and can never
become a man because that's not possible
so they are still just two women in a
lesbian relationship that's all that is
it's just what what actually happened is
that one of the women put on jeans and a
t-shirt and cut her hair that's that's
really what happened that was her
transformation into a man but here's the
main point and I've talked about this
many times you see how the left's
ideology of gender this gender fluidity
stuff has created so many internal
contradictions and it has undermined so
many of their other positions it's
really incredible to watch so plenty of
we've we've discussed in the past what
this has done to the feminist movement
where the feminist movement is all about
drawing this distinction between men and
women and saying that if you're a man
you're not allowed to have an opinion
about this you're not allowed to be
involved in this or that discussion and
it's so on and so forth but then when
you make gender fluid and so that a man
can actually be a woman it starts to
undermine all of that so we know about
that but there's another huge
contradiction here that you see with
this story we were told by the left for
for many years that sexual orientation
is ingrained genetic even and it cannot
be changed right am I crazy or have I
not been been told this over and over
again for years isn't this something
that we've been told you cannot change
sexual orientation and that's why these
gay conversion therapy is and always
that
all considered to be horrible disgusting
awful homophobic because it's not
possible you can't you're trying to
change something about someone that
cannot be changed something that is
something that is so deeply ingrained
and integral and immutable right well
but hold on if sexual orientation cannot
be changed and then a lesbian woman
becomes a man
and is still attracted to her female
lover well so now you're telling us that
that just that just changed from a
lesbian relationship into a heterosexual
relationship there was a changer so that
individual used to be a lesbian and is
now a heterosexual that's what you're
telling us so that means that sexual
orientation can change you can either
change or it can't and the thing is if
it can't change then certainly your sex
or your gender can't change because if
that changes then your orientation
changes so which is it and not to
mention just the the blatant absurdity
of this idea that your sexual
orientation could be ingrained and
biological but your sex is not that
simply makes no sense and as I said it
creates logical contradictions this
couple lesbian couple
they wore a lesbian couple before
weren't they now they're man and wife
according to you
that's heterosexual that is a different
orientation so it just changed which
means it can change which means that you
have to give up that that particular
line you can't keep saying them or you
can but you're contradicting yourself
alright let's go to emails a few good
ones I wanted to I wanted to address
Matt Walsh Oh edge
male comm is the emails try to remember
my email it's pretty easy you know email
address I don't know how I can forget it
Matt wall show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from this is also from a
a Matt it says hello divine dictator
Walsh I really didn't write this that is
how they address which finally someone
uses my correct title by the way I'm
tired of being misgendered says with
lint coming up upon those Catholics what
will you be giving up for Lent also for
those that are unsure what are useful
things for the soul to give up keep up
the good work well I believe pretty
strongly that we shouldn't advertise
what we're giving up for Lent as Jesus
says in Scripture when you when you fast
do it privately don't be a hypocrite
going around announcing it but I will
say that I think a good Lenten sacrifice
is anything anything that you'll feel
right and it's the same thing with
charity when giving the charity you're
supposed to give until it hurts if
you're giving if what you're giving to
charity you hardly even notice that
you're giving it because it doesn't
affect your lifestyle at all then you're
probably not giving enough and I think
it's the same thing with a with a Lenten
sacrifice like what you're thinking of
giving up it should fill you with some
real trepidation as you consider going
40 days without it you should be
thinking yourself I don't know if I can
do that that's I don't know so for
example and it's different for everybody
so for me I know that a lame sacrifice
for me in Lent and I've done this before
where I say okay I'm not gonna eat any
sweet so I'm not gonna eat any chocolate
or cookies or any kind of stuff but and
I I do like chocolate and cookies and
junk food don't get me wrong but I can
already go five or six days without even
really just having any real craving for
that it's not a big deal for me to not
eat that stuff so that's I think not a
good Lenten sacrifice I think it needs
to be something that I rely on a little
bit more but it also shouldn't be
something that is itself bad or immoral
because if it's bad or immoral then you
should just be giving it up anyway
permanently
not as part of a Lenten sacrifice so I
think the sweet spot here
no pun intended is something otherwise
good or neutral that you normally would
enjoy on a daily basis I think that's
what it's got to be so for me I think
one of the the ultimate sacrifice in
that vein would be if I gave up
something like coffee now for a lot of
people giving up coffee would be kind of
lame because they don't really need it
that much they don't drink that often
but I drink coffee all the time I love
coffee I depend on it especially in the
morning and so for me to give it up that
would be very very difficult and I've
never actually done that I I don't have
the guts I don't have the courage to do
that I just I can't imagine going 40
days without my cup of coffee but that
is that's see that's what I should
challenge myself to give up coffee and I
think it should be something in that in
that vein all right so let me read one
from Melissa I got very got many emails
like this as you can imagine I am NOT
going to read them all and many of them
I can't read because they're far too far
too vulgar but here's just one random
one that I chose so from Melissa it says
you disgust me your attack on Michael
Jackson a dead man in all caps who is
not in all caps here to defend himself
is sickening there is no evidence
against him none all caps this is a lie
and you are a liar you should be ashamed
of yourself
I was always a fan but I'm done with you
now I realize now that you're a piece of
s liar all right Melissa first of all I
want to tell you this sincerely I could
not be happier to lose your support I
couldn't be happier I am thrilled that
you'll no longer be listening or reading
I and I hope that you follow follow
through on that so let me just say that
I am NOT interested in having pedophile
defenders as fans I really I'm just not
so I think it's great that you're not
going to be listening to me you're
reading my stuff anymore
this is let's just call this a mutual
breakup between us I think it's best for
both of us so that's that's fun
in fact I assume you're not listening
right now so there's no reason for me to
address my response to you so to
everyone else first of all the fact that
Michael Jackson is dead and I heard this
over and over again he's dead he's dead
leave him alone so who cares that he's
dead
it doesn't make what he did any less
evil and the damage he did to the
families he destroyed will last forever
they're not getting over it when you
molest children those human beings are
going to have to live with that for the
rest of their life so the fact that
you're dead doesn't change that he may
be gone but the in the impact the the
awful impact of his evil predatory
behavior still lives on so that's why we
still talk about it as for there being
no evidence which again I heard over and
over again there's no evidence there's
no evidence this is just delusional
there is overwhelming evidence you know
usually or very often when it comes to
sex abuse child molestation rape
whatever the case may be very often
there isn't any evidence even if it
actually happened this is this is one of
the problems with with prosecuting cases
like this because you it's very
difficult to find actual evidence
especially if it's something that
happened in the past and and all of that
but in this one makes this case
different is that there is so much
evidence there is so much documented
evidence as opposed to what is usually
the case so I laid this out of my piece
yesterday but let me go over it again
and this is this is just I'm gonna give
you a small sampling of evidence there
there's so much more but all I'm gonna
focus on what is it seven pieces of
evidence that I think conclusively prove
that Michael Jackson was a monster and
so that he can absolutely be convicted
posthumously in the court of public
opinion even if he was not convicted in
a legal court and the fact that he was
not convicted legally in court doesn't
mean anything because
is a wealth mega rich wealthy beloved
celebrity who was able to essentially
purchase an acquittal for himself
because of his army of top lawyers
that's the thing as I talked about
yesterday if you if you're very very
very rich and it doesn't hurt to also be
very famous and you can buy the best
lawyers in the world and you have
unlimited resources it is going to be
very easy for you to literally get away
with murder
just ask Oh Jay Simpson especially if
your accusers are just are kids and
families who do not have anything close
to the resources that you have so that
doesn't mean anything to me we can look
at the evidence ourselves and come to
good so here's the evidence
number one Michael Jackson sought and
befriended prepubescent boys he took
these boys as companions he traveled the
world with them every so often he would
he would discard one of them and bring
in a new male companion
they were always boys they were always
young never adults never girls number
two Jackson lavished the boys families
with gifts and money and then he stopped
doing that the moment he moved on to
another boy this fact is not disputed in
the fact the first fact is not spirit
either number three Jackson invited the
boys to his home which was filled with
toys and candy this fact is not disputed
number four Jackson invited the boys
into his bed this fact is not disputed
number five its Jackson had a stash of
pornography right by that bed that fact
is also not disputed number six the bed
was in a room behind a locked door at
the end of a hallway equipped with alarm
systems to alert him whenever somebody
was approaching that fact also is not
disputed which leads us finally to the
last piece of the puzzle number seven
five of the boys who shared a bed with
Michael Jackson later accused him of
abuse that fact also is not disputed so
it's a cumulative case okay
I wrote this yesterday and saw Michael
Jackson defense
they went they went through each point
individually and tried to pick it apart
and they said they said well it's not a
crime to give people gifts that doesn't
prove anything
yeah no kidding Sherlock I'm not saying
that that alone proves anything as you
well know if all Michael Jackson ever
did was give gifts to random families I
would say he was a great man he was a
philanthropist but that's not what he
did you know he showered gifts on
families only if they were the only if
those were families with with boys who
slept in his bed you ever noticed that
he didn't pick out random no he never
lavished gifts on families unless there
was a boy that was a member of that
family who was sleeping in his bed why
do you think that is he's just a
coincidence
and by the way if all he ever did was
fill his home with child
children's toys and candy and amusement
park rides I would say that the guy was
a was a weirdo and kind of a freak but
but I would say that that alone isn't
that's all he was okay Bruce and that's
that's fine you could be a weirdo and a
freak if you want to be if that was all
there that ever happened but see each
piece fits with the next piece you have
to look at the entire 'but i say it's
cumulative you look at the entire
picture and you see how each thing goes
with the next goes what the next goes
with the next and then when you stand
back and you look at it you say oh well
this guy was a monster on balance the
evidence against Michael Jackson is so
strong that as I said yesterday even if
nobody had ever accused him we could
still say with near certainty that he
was a predator facts 1 through 6 are so
compelling on their own that you don't
even need facts 7 if not one person had
ever accused Michael Jackson I would
still be sitting here saying the guy was
a predator because there is no other
logical explanation for a guy seeking
out young boys to come sleep in his bed
no explanation none
if something walks like a duck and flies
like a duck and looks like a duck and
quacks like a duck it's still
technically possible that it's not a
duck it could be a tiny little elf or
something in a very realistic-looking
duck like airplanes flying around it
could be I can't say that it's not
I cannot if I'm looking at a duck
walking past me on the road I cannot
prove just by looking at it that it's
that there is not a little magical elf
inside the duck and it's a fake I can't
prove that but I think as a rational
person I don't really have to take such
a remote and fanciful fanciful
possibility into consideration when it
comes to ducks or pedophiles and the
point is that everybody this this is the
thing about everybody agrees with what
I'm saying here because if a guy named
Bob Smith or Mike Jones was in the habit
of befriended seven-year-old boys and
inviting him over for sleepover parties
and having them in his bed everybody
would agree that the guy was a creep and
a predator nobody would disagree only a
Michael Jackson case do we somehow give
him the benefit of the doubt because he
was a good singer and a good dancer but
the problem is that being a good singer
and dancer does not at all indicate that
you are not a pedophile doesn't mean
that you are obviously but it doesn't
mean that you're not it just it's not a
not a factor you can take it if you love
his music that just simply is not
something you can take and do
consideration it's got nothing to do
with this and I can see he was he was
very getting I think his songs are a
little overrated but I but he was gifted
in both areas and but he was also a God
forsaken monster this is it's just a
simple logic here and this is the way
logic works because because the other
thing people said to me people that were
a little bit less you know maybe not
Michael Jackson cult cultists but still
were you know I think sympathetic to
Michael Jackson some people in that camp
said said yeah you know there's there's
very good circumstantial case but you
can't know that you can never know
well yes but by that standard you can
never know anything right bye if you
really want to get down to it and be
very careful with your wording you can
never know anything I mean I can't even
I can't necessarily prove that I am
myself am NOT a very a sentient robot I
can't really I can't prove that I can't
prove that I'm not in the matrix I can't
prove that I was just created five
seconds ago and with with all the
memories implanted into my mind by space
aliens maybe the whole world was for all
I maybe the whole world was created five
seconds ago we were all given false
memories maybe the beginning of this
very show never happened it's all fake
can you prove that that's not the case
you can't but you can arrive at
conclusions based on very very high
levels of probability so there is a very
very very high level of probability that
you were born and that your life is real
and was not implanted into your mind by
space alien very high level probability
that's the case very very very low
probably level probability that it's not
the case so which means that's just
something that you know that's what we
mean when we say no you know that you're
real you know that you exist and so
that's what we mean and so when we look
at something like with the Michael
Jackson case you look at all this
evidence and you see this was a guy
sawed out little boys always had little
boys around him always young boys never
girls never adults had them in his bed
then was accused five times I mean it's
it's possible to come up with an
explanation that doesn't include him
being a monstrous pedophile it is
possible to imagine an explanation but
that explanation the probability of that
explanation being true is so
astronomically low that you can for all
intents and purposes discount it that's
how our court system works by the way
you know that
system is you are convicted beyond a
reasonable doubt but beyond a reasonable
doubt doesn't mean beyond any doubt
there could always still be a doubt but
beyond a reasonable doubt we come to a
reasonable conclusion in Michael
Jackson's case with his actual court
case they did not come to a reasonable
conclusion but we can so the most
reasonable by far the most reasonable
explanation for all of the factors that
I've listed is that Michael Jackson was
a pedophile that is by far the most
reasonable explanation any other
explanation is simply so unreasonable
that it can be discarded almost but not
quite with the same certainty that I can
discard the idea that I was just created
by space aliens five minutes ago
maybe I not with that same quite that
same level of certainty but still pretty
high level of certainty
all right we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching and I'm sorry
that for all the Michael Jackson fans
who are boycotting I wish I could say
I'm sad to see you go but I'm not
everyone else I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed